last time I talked to you I think we
were talking winter wedding it is the
winter where we add you got the ring on
your finger I have to be honest I'm so
excited and ready to marry Brian that we
were a little bit too antsy and what we
wanted to do it's like we want to get
married but planning a wedding is hard
and now that I realize it's not gonna be
on TV
I'm like I actually have to start
putting things in motion I would love to
get married the first half of 2019 and
now I'm like condensing it all making I
want it to be super small because I just
want to make it happen
okay you've got a really planet yeah
what happened with that cuz you were
kind of talking to me like look we'd be
open to it being on TV what went down
with that no I was always open to it
being on TV but listen the cards aren't
you know like a lining in the right way
and it just it's just not gonna happen
so I mean I guess I could always wait
for it to happen but I don't want to
keep waiting to marry the person that
I'm ready to you know spend the rest of
my life with does that mean I mean I
would have watched it does that mean
that like offers weren't presented to
you that like felt good or weren't right
or what happened nothing was specific
it's a little frustrating I mean it is
what it is you know I think I know it
has to do with scheduling and timing and
everything and so I'm not against that
but I'm not going to continue to put my
wedding on hold or my future on hold you
know for the person I want to spend the
rest of my life like it's not surprising
know that it wasn't offered no I think
it's a misconception that everybody
thinks that you get engaged you're
automatically getting a wedding but
that's not the case all right well let's
talk then about a first half of 2019
like any other details because you got
to plan it all now maybe a pantsuit what
do you think I well know I'm not wearing
a pantsuit anymore as much as I love a
good pantsuit and I'm getting them out
on the red carpet I'm gonna wear a dress
I think I would regret it at the end of
the day if I didn't wear a dress and I
want Brian to see me in a way that he
can't see me on a red carpet like
something special for our wedding day
something to make him cry
I feel like he's gonna cry he's a
sensitive guy he has a sensitive guy and
he makes me a sensitive girl no
seriously I was gonna I mean I know he
moved to Dallas for you I talked to you
guys there you've been traveling a ton
how are things with you guys and what
are you continuing to learn about each
other as things grow I mean I think
every day you learn something new about
the person that you're with but I think
that makes it beautiful you know if you
look at it in that positive way but I
mean like as we're together where our
love is growing stronger and stronger
we're not sure if we're gonna stay in
Dallas we're actually contemplating
Miami la is always on the table but now
we're really talking Miami as we're
thinking about building our family when
are we gonna build our family
I mean I'm ready to start now all right
yeah like you guys thought was that part
of why you're like wedding let's make it
happen
no I'm not there's no exclusive here I'm
not I'm not releasing a special
announcement but I mean if it happens it
happens
you know like I'm ready for a family you
guys are you okay with it happening
right now
I mean Ari and Lauren are are are
switching things up order what but they
also have a wedding day they have plans
they're putting things in motion I'm not
against them you know if it happens
we're not gonna fight it but I mean
we're not actively planning but you want
kids
oh I have 100% one kids with Brian can
you imagine how cute our babies are
gonna be I'm sorry shameless plug J to
anything looking back with some distance
now that you would have done differently
or like big things you learned about
being on reality TV I I truly feel like
I was myself you know I was even billed
as the super opinionated sassy bold
attorney and that's who I was on the
show and so I don't regret any of that
my only wish is that you got to see more
of Brian and you got to see why we fell
in love and why that was so special
that's why I always say that's the thing
is you guys are a success story you're
so happy you know and like I mean and I
love CNN let's get them still get that
wedding on TV guys don't want to watch
it if you guys can like recorded some
other yeah yeah there'll be some way
you'll see it and last questions for you
Ilan was it was announced that Ilan
parted ways with the franchise were you
shocked by that or do you know what
happens 100% I mean and it was weird how
it kind of came out I feel like we found
out from somebody else before we found
out from Milan himself but Elon is such
like a pivotal person a figure he's a
polarizing figure in the faster
franchise it's hard to imagine what a
season would be without Elon because he
was even big on my season and so I wish
him the best and everything that he's
doing it was definitely shocking to hear
that he's you know like not a part of
the franchise anymore I don't even know
what it looks like without him I was
gonna say yeah I mean what do you think
this means for the future of the show
will it change will I believe I don't
know we see it go a different way what
do you think I think the show has to
continue to change in light of social
media and everything that's happening
and sorry reality Steve like I guess
that's a plug for you Steve but like
everything that he's been able to leak
and just in light of everything that's
changing I feel like the show has to
constantly change its narrative and and
continue to excite the audience because
they're getting previews of things way
before they were ever before it's
changing rapidly I mean do you have any
idea why he did part ways no I I have no
I was shocked when I found out I
literally just texting Brian I was like
are you ready for the tea today
eat Alana's not a part of The Bachelor
franchise it was shocking
[Music]